Alexis Arquette dead at 47 et Canada  confirmed the actress and transgender  advocate best known for her roles in the  wedding singer and last exit to Brooklyn  died on Sunday give me time  to realize murkrow Alexis brother  Richmond revealed the sad news on  Facebook writing our brother Robert who  became our sister Alexis who became our  brother Alexis passed this morning  September 11th surrounded by all of his  brothers and sisters one of his nieces  and several of their loved ones  Richmond also shared that Alexis died  while listening to David Bowie song star  man the film star sibling added quote he  died as he lived on his own terms I am  humble and grateful to have been with  him as he began his journey onward  alexis had reportedly been suffering an  undisclosed illness ET has reached out  for comment